what's up babe listen I'm gonna be in
Vancouver next week Vancouver will be
February 22nd at the Vogue theater
that's a Wednesday February 24th Fresno
February 25th San Jose February 26
Sacramento March 16th Fort Myers 17th
Orlando 18th Jacksonville Boston all my
shows are sold out the 24th and 25th
thank you very much and September 22nd
New York City I have a humongous show it
is being announced next week save the
date September 22nd
Mercy yes Sally babes go what's up okay
I'm here uh pimp what's up sexy chickens
uh tonight I am in North Charleston babe
February 16th tomorrow we're in
Charlotte North Carolina uh the 18th in
the Del Lago Resort Casino in Waterloo
and then the 19th at the Capital One
arena in Washington DC coming up in
March we got Niagara Falls we got a big
one at the Prudential Center in Newark
on March 10th March 11th at the dome in
Wallingford Connecticut March 12th Long
Island where you at Long Island Stand Up
Man March 12th in Long Island the UBS
Arena this is basically our hometown
show can't wait to see you guys and then
we got Milwaukee Rosemont Seattle
Portland Boston and so on and so we we
redid Boston because the pipes broke
yeah the pipes broke 429 back at the
wing and I think we're adding a show but
don't say nothing I told you
everything's on sale right now and
impracticaljokerslive.com I'll see you
guys on the road
guys if you want to win meet and greet
tickets uh to see us on the road on tour
we do not sell them we are not doing
them the only way you could win them is
buy this contest I'm about to tell you
about right now every single Thursday
night at 10 o'clock Eastern there are
new episodes from Practical Jokers
season 10 right now all you got to do is
take a picture of you watching the
episode it could be with friends family
or alone naked eating a bowl of cereal
hashtag
jokerswatch party on any social you have
and every single week including tonight
and every Thursday we are going to pick
winners and give away tickets to the
tour and meet and greets is the only way
you can get a meet and greet tonight's
episode is post Malone he's the best
check it out again every single Thursday
night at 10 on true and TBS hashtag
jokerswatch party I hope to meet you and
greet you on the road
[Music]
you know that about it baby oh girl you
know what's up and you know what I mean
what I've been listening to on Spotify
90s hip-hop I love it I love it when I
go when I'm on the road when I say r b r
b though right r b i do that's early
2000s r b Donell Jones yeah that no
that's 90s baby is it yeah late late 90s
yeah Donell Jones that and this love all
this love
oh you don't give it up cause you'll be
great now say it again
one of my favorite things is you singing
like earnestly and an r b and over the
blues yeah yeah r b is where I feel
nostalgic it's where I feel good I that
was our [__] that's right late 90s I
swear to God I feel the safest in my
life like I feel so safe and so at home
and connected when I'm singing along to
things that 16 year old black girls from
1997 will be singing along yes that's
how I feel that is what I love as well
and I'm not even joking and also
speaking of late 90s hip-hop and r b in
early r b the glasses suited thank you
right now okay I swear to God right now
you could just you could easily be
Donald Jones right in front of me Donald
Jones right now I'm Jeffrey Dahmer I'm
everybody I'm my father from the 80s yes
here's the thing is people some people
it's been 50 50 on on how people feel
about it and what I want to say that
purple tint by the way you think I don't
notice it smashing his shirts buddy what
did I notice yeah in the words of Kanye
West if they want to hate Lem hate watch
the money pile up I missed a line in
there somewhere but I don't want to go
go to go do full Kanye on the first five
minutes also in the words of Kanye
poopity scoop poopity scoop yeah I
genuinely thought yesterday during this
uh well four days gone out when the
Super Bowl throwing Super Bowl halftime
show I thought Rihanna was going to
bring out Kanye that's what I thought
was going to happen really
there was some prop bets that Jay-Z
would be there right and then I we were
gonna bet it because my friend my my
friend his sister-in-law is the nanny of
Beyonce and Jay-Z what yes you so you
have a connection to Beyonce I don't
have any I don't have any connection but
you have somewhat you're not that far
removed from Beyonce and Jay-Z's you
could be you could in a pinch babies
if push came to shove and the right
calls were made yes I could be watching
the kids blue was it Blue Ivy Blue Ivy
yeah good kid yeah um now we got to give
a shout out to the Kansas City Chiefs
you gotta give a shout out to Patty
Mahomes Patty Mahomes he's a young guy
with a rocket for an arm and he's got
great decision making yes he plays
through adversity he hurt his angle you
got to give it up to them for winning
the Super Bowl and the biggest thing
about I mean literally not only is he an
amazing player are the Chiefs now a
dynasty okay but the fact in the world
that we live in I would imagine the NFL
has to be absolutely creaming themselves
that not only that that means like
ejaculating ejaculating themselves right
that Patrick Mahomes is not only their
best player uh no you know the the he'll
be the NFL MVP probably the Super Bowl
MVP they've won the Super Bowl they are
the the face of the NFL team-wise but
Patrick Mahomes is racially ambiguous
yeah marketing standpoint it's just
Yachts
because it you know it's one of it you
have to be and I literally he's a
generation he's a once in a general I
mean you can't get that first of all
he's got the whole he's got his whole
future ahead of him still but still
let's Peak Performance let's break down
Patrick Holmes first of all he has the
hair of Valentino yeah the skin of a
light-skinned black man yeah the eyes of
a white man the work ethic of an Asian
yeah
um uh uh um the the
um let's he bro he sprained his ankle
um which would be um he's got the
fashion sense of uh he's got the fascist
gay of a fierce gay yeah um he hurt his
ankle and then hobbled off like a Jewish
person would that's right um then they
shot him up with with a bunch of
probably stuff in his leg like like a
crackhead like a crackhead would um he
just came back out like a meth head of
you yeah he was able to perform even
though his leg fell off yeah yeah he
actually when he won the Super Bowl he
got on his knees like a Muslim wood
because he knew that it was about that
time yeah
um it's about that time and I just think
Patrick Mahomes he literally he in
encompasses what what a human being is
and I think the NFL I think I almost
think if the NFL is rigged but there's a
lot of talk about the NFL's rig I could
see how they rigged it former homes the
stock went up all the way up yes
I think that like yeah he's he's
literally if they made a player like in
a lab yes the NFL did they would make
him like how how they made Carly Rae
Jepsen's music in a lab that's right
it's like they made Patrick Mahomes
football career in a lab and now he's
Super Bowl three the last four years
with two rings uh you can't count out
the organization themselves you gotta be
remiss if we didn't say the organization
shout out the organization and Shout out
the name has uh Chiefs you know Redskins
went down Indians went down Chiefs
because I guess Chiefs is not derogatory
you're saying I am the top level of the
Native American uh yeah social structure
right right right but we were trying to
guess what the post headlines would be
yesterday and uh my friend said uh uh oh
what the hell was it
uh something Chief like
you know how people like Yay Chief yeah
yeah they say what do they [__] say
what's up Chief no you're about like
they won so it's like all good Chief all
good or something like that we had a
laugh over it right I'm not conveying it
right
will we be remiss if we didn't mention
the Philadelphia Eagles we have to
mention the Philadelphia Eagles we love
the people of Philadelphia and we the
city did the city burn down the city did
actually almost gonna burn down it was
actually worse and and I want to say to
the people of Philadelphia if you're
listening and we know that you are yeah
don't worry about it you'll get them
next Sunday
shout out to Jalen hurts who's who's uh
another another Hottie with the body
yeah plays two years of the NFL Jalen
hurts plays the entire NFL game being
tackled by grown Superior men all day
with a probably 25 000 gold earring in
his ear never takes it off it never
takes it and the chain saquan Barkley a
lot of these NFL players they play with
fifty thousand dollar plus jewelry it
never breaks it's silly to me though
it's it is silly it seems like it's just
a terrible decision actually it's Silly
Willy but you know listen but part of
that part of their entire
the way that we judge him as a player is
for the decision-making skills in the
moment yes so you would think that when
it comes to wearing Jewels right uh in a
physical game like that yeah the
decision making takes a hot [__] if you
ask me hot [__] yeah yesterday my grant
my dad asked my daughter on FaceTime who
you um who you she goes so who are you
gonna root for who do you want to win
the Super Bowl and my daughter said the
Kansas City chickens oh
but earnestly she was like the Kansas
City Chicken why is it not a chick there
should be a team that's a chick right I
would love that I would like to play
chicken for the chicken it was like just
like that minor league baseball team the
Savannah bananas they sell out every
game strictly off their name like my
daughter said she wants me to take her
to see a savannah banana cake yeah she
has to
you would would you would you root for
the the New York chickens I would roof
for the New York there should be a team
the New York rats I think that would be
a good franchise the New York rats the
New York sewer rats the New York's yeah
maybe yeah you think sewage you don't
want to attach to it yeah but that's
where it's from we all know it what
about the New York garbage man I would
like that my dad was a sanitation man
shout out sanitation yeah I wore I I was
gifted with a sanitation I want to shout
out I want to shout out uh Mario vatulo
uh from bellato's restaurant balado's
restaurant New York City on Houston
Street if you haven't been I think the
best red sauce joint in New York City
unbelievable food Mario one of the
family owners there gave me a dsny
sweatshirt and a dsny T-shirt and I
loved it people have been asking me
where'd you get that from somebody goes
is that kiss I was like No it's it's 25
probably less than 25 I got it from an
actual garbage man yeah dude my dad was
in sanitation I used to wear all his
clothes it's awesome like when I was in
college I was like that whole like
vintage retro weird [__] or whatever
like grunge and I used to wear a
sanitation jacket a sanitation shirt
like a button down like a uniform shirt
yeah uh shout out tombolo shout out
tombolo tambolo is a company that I
found online that I uh that I like I
bought a couple of pieces from them and
uh they did a sanitation line thing and
I have a sanitation like a sanitation
hat and a New York sanitation uh uh uh
terry cloth shirt shot him out a whole
nice outfit and then they found out that
I liked it they sent me even more stuff
so a good tip of the cat shout out
tombolo yeah I love you Tomball I
thought it was a region in Africa no
yeah that too that too yeah shout out
Africa by the way good country good
continent absolutely yeah yes of course
yeah aren't hickeys weird hickeys are
weird I would never want a hickey I've
had one in my life and I was it was
painful to get and then it was weird to
have yeah and and it used to be a goal
when we were younger you're doing the
70s and 80s Show yes it's actually out
now it's called super maximum retro show
coming out March 7th on Vice there you
go hickies were abound in the 70s and
80s hickies were like in Vogue yeah you
don't see many people with hickeys right
now what was the last time you saw
someone in the wild with a hickey truly
I I haven't even thought about it I
haven't seen I haven't seen a fist fight
in public or anybody with a hickey in a
long time I bet you one day you see both
right yeah fighting over hickeys yeah
yeah you know one time I saw a fist
fight in my neighborhood and I saw a guy
get punched in the face and it was like
a movie like rolled over the hood of a
car like he got hit so hard that he
rolled over the hood oh you sure it
wasn't a movie and then
you know what it could have been yeah
were they filming yeah it could have
been yeah no it wasn't though okay it
wasn't but it could have been
um but no that's interesting that you
say that about a hickey because I
haven't even thought about like if if
you ever give one yes that's the thing I
tried I might have tried in my lifetime
when we were younger I was like oh you
gotta but I don't even think kids today
even it's even on their radar no right
no I think if they sucking other things
today I think if a kid came in yes yeah
I think if a kid came in today with a
hickey
they it would be like what they would
they would be concerned like what do you
bruise is that like is that a new
booster what is that they wouldn't know
what that they wouldn't think it was
sexually sexually related at all but
think of how crass it is in general
grass is a good word thank you so much
that you don't hear enough no you don't
but people used to walk around with
mulch multiple hickies can you believe
that now here's another question that's
weird okay I understand hickeys were big
in the 70s 80s but were they big in like
the 1770s and 80s do you think there was
somebody like were [__] something
that were being done and received in the
1500s do you think do you think through
the second the caveman saw that he had a
penis he was getting put in his mouth
even himself he was everybody was
sucking everybody back then probably it
is a weird thing because when you think
about that like you would never like you
know want to swallow a booger or like
even spit like having someone spin you
out but but common vaginal fluids it's
everyone's like sign me up they'll drink
it all day every day no problem except a
high percentage of African-American men
so I hear they won't do it I hear that
100 well I'll tell you right now you're
not getting DJ cattle to do it he will
not no he's very vocal about that and so
I know right now if I ever became a
woman or I I used a genie and I became a
woman and if I was dating him he's not
going to do it to me he's not gonna
drink your vaginal he's not going to he
says it out loud he's a king that won't
do it interesting that's what he says
well you know nobody believed him God
did God God did yes God did yes well
that's the thing when you look back to
the through the past you have very
prominent people George Washington died
of throat cancer Napoleon Bonaparte lung
cancer they think it was uh uh uh in the
throat uh vaginally related they don't
say that but how well because if you're
a you know George Washington Napoleon
your kings conquerors what you're
probably going to do is is is is go down
on women I would think everything not
smoking Newports no they couldn't be
right so I think a lot of these I think
a lot of people died of of eating puss
and we just don't talk about it and we
should talk about it and that's what
this podcast is about yeah yeah thanks
for joining us today on eating puss yeah
uh papers but I think I I think that the
hickeys probably started way back like
Transylvania like that kind of thing
yeah Dracula Dracula the original
Dracula you know the original Dracula
was a like a very bad bad guy he's real
so Dracula right Vlad the actual Vlad
Dracula Vlad the Impaler yeah you've
heard of him of course okay so Bram
Stoker wrote Dracula like whatever it is
the late 1800s I believe so he took
Dracula Vlad the imperialist real story
which wasn't really that well known and
kind of made this character Dracula
because the real Vlad the Impaler yeah
was probably even more psychotic and
worse than the actual Draco they so we
were talking about this before Vlad the
real Transylvania was in Romania which
we don't know if Romaine romaine lettuce
comes from Romania you don't know we're
talking about before the cameras rolls
we don't know and which is interesting
and we don't know Romaine here's two
things about Romania one romaine lettuce
we don't know if it comes from the two
the Roman Empire named is named after
Romania named themselves after the Roman
Empire so it's like you wouldn't think
of Romania these days as being like this
prominent country but the Roman Empire
did they named the country Romania after
themselves wow very interesting the
Impaler tell me about him let me tell
you about the Impaler so Vlad the
Impaler not to be confused with Vlad the
Impala right from Compton from Compton
right or Vlad Guerrero Hall of Fame
baseball player correct yeah or Vlad Mir
Putin or Vlad Putin yeah yeah or Vlad TV
or Vlad TV you know who that is yeah
yeah great show Yeah okay or there's
probably a kid with asthma right now
called Vlad the inhaler yeah and another
dad jokes
it's going to be happening with these
listen this is about dad jokes yes
um so tell me about Vlad the Impaler
Vlad the Impaler that's a name that's a
name do you know one person gave him
that name we're talking about today yeah
it that always if you just keep
distilling things down to their natural
Roots yeah it's always like oh someone
had the idea for a chair there was one
person someone had everything everything
all of our vernacular everything stemmed
from one person at one moment most
likely unless there were just like you
know like they say parallel thoughts
across places that you know oh this is
this is this rock rolls I don't know
right but someone said Vlad the Impaler
because what he would do was one person
one person so he he was notoriously
brute so so here's what happened with
him is he would fight you haven't have
you heard of him at the Conqueror big
big months big like want to like the
topmost upstairs like this
okay yeah Oz who is also a big Muslim
but not as big as I'm at the Conqueror
if you would have been able to take
Pennsylvania maybe okay but Mehmet Oz
uhmet to conqueror conqueror he was what
happened was is you know basically back
in the day
you know Islam was like you know they
were it you know it was it was the
Christian Christians versus the Islam
Islam right and it was big big war which
they're not fighting anymore but so
that's since been so yeah so so they put
their differences behind them yes so it
was a big war and um and so
so basically Mehmet the Conqueror and
vlad's father okay Vlad the impaler's
father there were two brothers and
vlad's father lost in a battle to met
the conqueror's father and so as a like
thing like an exchange like they they
did they did like a prison exchange and
Vlad the impaler's father basically gave
basically gave up his own Sons to Mehmet
the conqueror's father and these
Christian kids were now going to be
raised by an all-muslim faction I met
the conquerors uh uh father took in
these kids because he had just beat his
father in war so Vlad the Impaler is
living with moment the Conqueror and his
brother living with him at the Conqueror
and they're having these these Crusades
like you know the muzzies versus the the
Muslims versus the Christians and blah
blah blah blah and Vlad the Impala
eventually escapes and then Vlad the
Impaler starts to make his own what do
you call a little Muslim baby
fresh muzzy
that's it please continue that's it I
love it
um
yeah and forget about it Vlad and Vlad
and parallel when they were living with
him at the Conqueror Vlad the Imperial
yeah Vlad the Impaler vlad's brother and
moment the conqueror's son you know what
they used to call themselves The Three
Musketeers
and no but that's true that's another
dad's that's a joke put the Dow Jones
counter up yeah Three Musketeers yeah
um I'd like to see the mailbox it's like
yeah I'm at the Conqueror yeah
so so
um
um Vlad the Impaler says why do you give
him his sons
because basically what happened was is
in moment the Conqueror we met the
Conqueror won we met the conqueror's
Father the Islams basically beat the
Christians in one of these wars and so
Vlad the Impaler one of his territories
about to be taken over and he was like
don't take over my territories I'll give
you my kids instead just leave me alone
how's that a fair trade because he
because back then people didn't care
about their kids they just didn't give a
[__] but I'm saying to the other guy
what why would he want some kids instead
of of his land
I don't know okay that well you don't
know everything that's the thing I don't
know yeah Ed and I'm not gonna try to
make something up here oh no you never
do that I never do that so by the way
speaking of making things up I'll just
deviate and then I will get back that
show Howie Mandel show the [__] game
show is so fun to watch there's a show
called the [__] it's the name of it
is the [__] game show on Netflix me
and my kids were watching that show for
like 10 hours on Saturday okay because
you can't you don't know if the person's
bullshitting or not it's so good and
then I had literally I swear to God my
one-year-old daughter went [__]
[Music]
but a lot but Delilah was saying
[__] I didn't care so
so basically Vlad to fight he eventually
starts to get he fight he needs to fight
the Islam Islamic people and what he
already lost well his dad lost but now
Vlad wants to but vlad's living with my
met now Vlad was the moment but then
Vlad escaped Vlad escaped back to his
home in Vlad Vladimir went home to his
father who gave him away his father was
dead this was the you know you don't you
don't leave you know his father died at
35 he lived a great life okay so you
know at those times sure so Vlad goes
back to Romania Transylvania and says we
gotta repel the Muslims once and for all
so he says in what he wants to do is he
was a fierce Warrior Vlad the Imperial
was known in these streets as being like
the best fighter like he was like the
the the number like the the uh who's
like the best UFC fighter who's like the
most
uh John Paul Jones
all related to him at the concert so so
the Vlad the Impaler is like the best
fighter so what he does and people don't
really want to mess with him all right
this podcast episode is sponsored by
betterhelp you know Sal and I talk about
better help almost every week here we
did a whole episode talking about what
we've learned in therapy how we're
trying to get better as people
and better help helps with that uh in
more ways than I can tell you mental
health we're all struggling with mental
health lately it's so important to take
care of your mental health Mind Body
Connection and better help is awesome
you can do it all from the comfort of
your own home it's all online
um it's all uh they match you take a
survey they match up with the best
licensed professional for you to talk to
um if you're thinking giving of giving
therapy a try better help is in my
opinion the best option
um all you do is like I said fill out
that brief questionnaire get matched
with the licensed therapist and boom
it's awesome it's convenient it's
flexible it's affordable and to me it's
necessary and not having to leave the
house amazing if you want to live a more
empowered life and get therapy you can
start today by going to betterhelp.com
hey babe and you're going to get 10 off
your first month okay just put in the
promo code hey babe 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash go do it all right
blue chew listen
we as guys sometimes we need a little
bit of help okay and you know me I like
to be stiff okay I am they call me
Chrissy stiff they call me Christy
Bluetooth because everybody knows I use
it I'm open about it I love it my family
loves it my everybody in my family loves
that I'm using Bluetooth I'm walking
around at barbecues so stiff I mean
literally they're flipping burgers off
my piece and it's it's it's awesome
now what Bluetooth it's a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost my friend Pat Samaha uses it and he
literally he's changed his life I mean
this kid I go to the gym with his kid
and he's lifting 30 pound dumbbells with
his Lebanon live with his Lebanese [__]
and it's just awesome Bluetooth tablets
are made in the USA that's why I'm
wearing this USA shirt baby because this
is where Bluetooth is made and they get
prepared and shipped direct to your door
in a discreet package the best part it's
all done online no doctors visits no
awkward combos no waiting in line at the
pharmacy it's just Bluetooth to your
Dell and right now if you we always give
you discounts here if you go to
bluetooth.com and put in the promo code
hey babe you're gonna get your first
month free so go visit bluetooth.com go
put in the promo code hey babe first
month free go there this gives important
safety information so you know and and
it's great and it's easy and I want to
thank blue you for sponsoring the
podcast
whenever he gets named Vlad the Impaler
is because what he does to anybody that
messes with him or what he does when the
Muslims are coming can I take a wild
guess take a guess does he impale him
yes he does but here's the way he does
it what he does is while you're alive a
lot of people would kill you and then
impale your body
on the on you know after you're dead
what he does is gets you gets you know
in in the Town Square spread eagle takes
a dull like kind of just not really that
sharp goes in with skill technicians
through your ass your anus anal cavity
misses all the vital organs pops it out
of your shoulder puts you on a stake in
the middle of the road in the Blazing
heat takes you about three to five days
to die typically if the if they don't
catch any vital organs which is most
skilled impalers new to miss the vital
organs and then pop you out of the
shoulder and that's why they were cold
impalers because their job was to impale
people without without hitting an organ
so that they can die a slow death Under
the Sun and as as the Army invading Army
was coming in they would see all the
soldiers that had been there two weeks
before that had you know instead of
taking prisoners that's what he would do
he would impale everybody but he
wouldn't pale he would impale soldiers
women children he didn't care he just
didn't care
why
couldn't he just kill him
because he was known as the Impaler so
he didn't want to kill but did he start
that
he I don't know if he started but he's
definitely made it famous okay other
people have now impaled because of him
like he's basically like Elvis Presley
yes he's the Elvis Presley okay yeah he
created yeah and so he's got to be a
certain type of guy
to impale people and leave them under
the sun impaled just dying a slow death
well at the time at the time that's why
Bram Stoker got the idea to write
Dracula because at the time the people
who were living with Vlad Dracula AKA
Vlad Dracula were saying that he must be
like a Satanist he like wants to like he
would want to drink their blood too he
would drink their blood as it was like
dripping so he would do that so his name
was Vladimir Dracula his name was Vlad
his name in these streets in real life
was Vlad Dracula Dracula comes from him
so Dr you would think like Dracula was
just like a common last name in Romania
at the time like there's a guy out there
named John Dracula that's like this
sucks I'm like a good guy I'm anti-satan
but I grew up in Romania what about what
about count chocula count charcoal is a
cereal that's based on Dracula yeah and
takes his name from that and if you knew
where this was coming from it's it's
based on Vladimir Dracula the Impala who
used to just impale people now even a
chocolate cereal yeah it's not it's not
it's not it's it's like oh like you know
like you can't uh you know like oh it's
like instead of Applejacks these are
Hitler Jacks and people like oh I love
it so Dracula Dracula is a vampire
Dracula was a vampire for Bram Stoker
because they did he make up vampires
Bram Stoker no Bram stokers did Bram is
a funny name Bram is a funny name it's
Raisin Bran yeah what's Bram show for
uh I don't know brahmamine which is uh
or bromine which is the chemical and
pineapple that when you eat pineapple
when you're makes your semen smell sweet
if you want to swallow it over today no
it's true you never you never you never
ate pineapples jerked off it smelled
your own semen no you're weird yeah
um so so so did Bram Stoker make up
vampires I that part is when I that's
another one I don't know I think that he
because people took that and ran with us
well he's not getting dividends on all
these other things on all these other
vampires no no but I know the original
story was because Vlad Dracula the real
vladder cooler was such a heinous
character in history that they wrote us
nationalized I made money off of him
then so Bram Stoker's maybe not a good
guy
um well it's capitalism that's the thing
are you a good guy I don't know I don't
know you could say that making money off
of all these people that were tortured
but it happened a long time I guess
because it happened so long ago he also
I mean he created a fictionalized story
yeah I don't know it's a good question
wait wait Bram Stoker is only
what years Bram Stoker if I had to guess
Bram Stoker and pimp if you could Google
this I'm going to say Bram Stoker wrote
Dracula in 1881. okay so then he didn't
know what his vampires existed before
that no I don't think so concept of a
vamp well what do we got pimpy
1897. whoa he didn't invent vampires but
he made like the Romantic yeah just like
just like you know back to back just
like you know that you know when you see
a flag that's skull and bones when you
see Skull and Bones yeah what do you
think of when you see that like poison
death sure the Jolly Roger well the
Jolly Roger no no so oh so he's poison
ready for this ready forget ball spawn
off yeah the Jolly Roger those pirate
flags that was made like in the 60s
that's not real okay where the where the
where the ball Skull and Bones comes
from what Israel why you associated with
evil and death is because that was the
Nazi flag no that was an SS tank that
was an SS division Nazi flag that had
skull and bones and they Associated that
with evil and that's how we know it now
but that's going Bones on none of that
is real okay
was it [__] [__] no it's not
that's actually real okay yeah oh wow
okay no yeah so so it's interesting like
when you look back at history sometimes
you're like oh a lot of this stuff is
just like you know look there's no
reason we've talked about this before
there's no reason to drink cow's milk
it's just that's the industry right
that's just the we can Mass produce that
but hickeys this is all because they get
back to it yeah if you saw someone
walking down the street with three
hickeys what's your immediate what do
you feel what do you what do you think
about that person okay they got after it
do you feel like they're fun and
free-spirited do you feel like they
don't have they're uncouth do you feel
like maybe they're promiscuous honestly
I would think they were playing
paintball okay that's what I said just
lit up you got hit in the neck yeah I
would say I would say you don't protect
a neck
I would think honestly if I saw an adult
I'll tell you what I'm at a point now
where if I saw an adult with a hickey
like if you came in with a hickey yeah I
I would be like what an awesome like I
would be happy for you I'd be like how
fun was that really yeah I wouldn't be
embarrassed by it anymore if I was 21
I'd be embarrassed by it but as a 38
year old guys I think I'd be mortified
no I see at this point I'd be like you
know what you're living your life you're
having fun who gives a [__] if you were
necking I make a point with a gal right
she said to you please give me a hickey
like if you went on a date and the girl
was like I'd like a hickey please would
you oblige I think you have to because I
think that um I think you know you want
people to feel comfortable so I would
say if if me sucking your neck so hard
that I literally break blood vessels in
your neck is going to make you feel like
this date was worth it I'll do it and
then when someone's like I want to give
you a hickey that I can't do you can't
do that that I can't do yeah well I
literally give her me a hickey or like
on my nipple or something like on a
place where you're not gonna see me you
know what I mean but what is the point
it can't be pleasurable I got one once
it was painful as [__] it does suck yeah
how come when you're getting a [__]
you don't get a hickey
you ever think about that why don't you
get it if you're literally saying I'm
asking your I'm sucking your D yeah but
it don't I don't get a hickey but if you
suck my neck I get a hickey it's the
same skin why is it called a hickey
pimp
I'm gonna guess
um
something with the South
what is it pimpy
the origin of the word is from its
earlier meaning of pimple skin lesion
okay
pimples but I don't know where they got
hickey from yeah
pimp you're not the only person in the
room with glasses now not as how does
that make you feel that I'm coming after
you yeah perfect too well they're
sunglasses they're transition lenses by
the way I want to show you those are
those are those are not oh the
transitions they're transitional so what
happens so but I want to shout out
Anthony Aiden Optical on St Marks and
2nd Avenue in the city this he's the guy
that got in these frames he's awesome he
Bobby Kelly shouted him out on Rogan and
that's how I discovered the idea I went
to the uh I don't because he does
Bobby's he does Bobby's glasses but
Bobby needs prescription glasses I don't
yet but what I did need is the eye
doctor told me he could tell just from
looking at my eyes that I don't wear
sunglasses when I'm driving and he's
like you need a pair of sunglasses
because he said you have like sun scars
like on your eyes like from like I can
you could just tell I don't know why wow
so I wanted to get sunglasses and I want
to go to Anthony alien but then because
I'm doing this 80s 70s 80s Vice show I
was like I want something cool frames he
was like I got you and he's like I got
ones that'll hook cool that you can wear
them like and then they transition which
is perfect which is in this day and age
is perfect that's what you want so we so
they get darker they get darker and if I
when I'm driving brighter the darker
right so if I'm in the sun these are
full shapes they become they transition
with the UV light they sometimes they
sum out and then they de-transition when
you get out of the UV light so he put
them under a UV light in the shop and
they were like literally like I'm like
I'm a cop like dark but purple and now
they're just like this light light like
pinkish purple well they're turning the
natural state of them is to be pinkish
purple okay but you can wear them with
anything like I happen to be wearing a
purple sweatshirt but you'll see when I
take the sweatshirt up they'll still be
pinkish purple that's not reacting off
the shirt okay it's just pinkish purple
at base and and so right now they're not
sunglasses they're just fashion lenses
right now I would say these are
fashionistas right now I'm going for it
is what I'd say you are they're they are
because you have the you have the chain
here yeah what do you call this thing
are you a watch guy sure do you know
about watches not much but I'm saying a
watch guy in the sense of like Rolex AP
Patek Philippe like would you ever
invest in a watch okay I'm not that guy
I it's I'm friends that are that guy I
did I did buy a Rolex okay I bought one
for me and my dad do you ever wear them
I do wear them on on special occasions I
should wear it like every day but it's
not an everyday watch what type of Rolex
is it a Rolex watch a Cellini oh a
Cellini that's a nice watch it's
beautiful and they appreciate and value
and you've got you got a matching one
with your dad I got my dad it's a
Cellini as well but mine is he's a
little different his was actually more
expensive he has a little diamonds in it
right yeah but mine's my very plain Jane
but he had the diamonds in them so he
got so you got the Rolex Cellini he got
the Rolex Salini Dion
my dad got me a gift one time and he got
me a a tag which is not crazy expensive
but it's not not crazy it's nice yeah my
point is is that watches are is is a
piece of jewelry that typically
appreciated and it's not a bad
investment a watch is not a jewelry I'm
not the guy that's going to get blinged
out joy although right tell me what you
guys think of this I wanted some type of
like chain right so what I'm getting is
a pendant okay let's I'm getting you are
jewelry you're wearing you're wearing
Cuban links to get a chain yeah but but
but not like CR like I'm not gonna spend
thousands of dollars up I'm not doing
that yeah but what I am going to get
yeah is I'm getting
uh a chain with a pendant well it's
gonna be three pendants with each you
know Tristan Delilah and violet with
their fingerprints on the back I I'm
gonna I got their fingerprint like in
ink you think that's good or is that
like weird well what's on the front
their name it would be Tristan with his
fingerprint on the back Delilah hers
Violet and three hang from one chain is
that yeah I need to visualize four three
with three chain or is it three with
three chains which is it but then it's
getting too much money yeah no I need to
visualize what you mean I can't imagine
three pendants hanging off one gold
chain but maybe I can
am I are you making this up in your head
or you've seen it I've seen it and I
want to do it and how do you get the
fingerprints now they got to commit they
gotta commit like crimes no well that
well I I I went on Amazon and I got an
ink pad and I was gonna do it and the
guy said just put it their fingers in
ink put it on a piece of printer paper
and then
write their names and give me three ones
to choose from for each child text it to
me I'll make it for you I'll make it for
you I'll text it to you you said text it
we've come that far text to fingerprints
they'll be able then to take it
digitally put it on their machine and
make the fingerprints and gold wow yeah
it's my guy Yani from Material Goods
shout out Yanni great guy you you now
have guys everywhere now literally got a
glasses guy you got a pendant guy I got
a watch guy well the jewelry guy and the
glasses guy is the same guy one in the
same Yanni from Material Goods connected
to me through tank Sinatra Shout Out
Tank Sinatra okay
um who is actively on steroids he's very
open about it oh wow really fully open
no [__] trying to get me to get take
testosterone I I I can't do it don't
isn't taking testosterone
no well here's the thing if you take
testosterone I know a person who here's
who I know I know a guy and I I will I
will eventually say his name in public
but I know a guy who um I know a guy who
has a ponytail who who yeah at who got
test who got tests testosterone we
called they called test in the streets
TST I was writing tests for a while and
then tank was like it really annoys me
when you call a test it's test I was
like okay so I'll say test but I know I
know a guy with a ponytail who got tests
how he ready for this he got it
surgically implanted two test tablets or
three in his ass in the bottom of his
ass crease you know like that little lip
under your ass when like a cheek right
in there they surgically implanted three
test tablets in his ass okay for a week
you can't do any deep squats you can't
do anything working out it now is
pumping testosterone into his body for
the next six months he supposedly in the
next month or two is going to be
absolutely jacked and shredded he did
tell me he went from being able to do
two pull-ups to being able to do over 15
pull-ups in two weeks which is nuts and
I believe him
um here's the issue every day I think
there's a lot of issues every day yes
the the ponytail is the least of his
issues yeah yeah every day every day you
have to take an estrogen pill every day
because what happens is your body then
starts to think oh I don't need to make
testosterone anymore because these
tablets are making a forest so we shut
the factors and that's how your body is
your body's very black and white even if
you're Puerto Rican or Chinese your
body's still very black and white sure
because they just say if I stop moving
my arm that's why frozen frozen shoulder
is a problem if you hurt your hand if
you hurt your shoulder you hurt your arm
you break your arm say you have to
always move your hands because that
signals to your brain we still need the
arm if you don't want atrophy if you
don't know what happens is it's called
adhesive capsulite it's frozen shoulder
if you're if you hurt your arm and
people don't move they literally don't
they can't move their arm because the
brain says these this [__] guy hasn't
moved his arm in about two days it must
be gone shut it down shut it down send
all and they basically put on his mail
get he's done what up the windows so
that's what they say with the
testosterone they say he's not this guy
has no use for stop making it they get
really pissed off they go stop making
the testosterone I can't handle this
[__] like this so how is he getting
pumped testosterone from tablets that
are if or isn't there a finite amount of
testosterone on the tablets that he's
being pumped also like a Time release
maybe okay see like an Alka-Seltzer so
he walks into a place and he basically
said he basically drops his pants he
bends over something I imagine they put
him out and then they go to surgery in
his ass crack just so he can increase
his pull-ups here's the thing I think
that it's becoming a thing the
testosterone ACA Market is becoming a
thing like a fountain of youth thing
where a lot of scientists are saying
we've been misled by the science
Industry that steroids are not that bad
for you testosterone is not that bad for
you all these things are not that bad
for you as long as as you take what
you're what what this guy has to do take
the estrogen pills because then if you
don't take these pills take that
estrogen you you yes you you start to
develop man boobs the other thing you
have to do more and more if you don't
take the estrogen stock development
because what happens is you stop
producing the testosterone exactly but
you're not getting enough from the s i
no no you're getting more than enough
for the S but your body's not producing
it okay so then your body stops making
testosterone if you don't take this
other counterbalance pill then you start
to develop man boobs the second thing
you have to do ironic is you start to
lose your hair for some reason I don't
know the sign to that when you start on
testosterone you start to lose your hair
so you have to take these pills to make
sure to make sure uh now you could
preventively I'm sure go to keeps.com
and do that hey babe I'm sure but tank
doesn't do it though tank doesn't do it
he's bald AF yeah so he's bath so so
sorry fourth dad joke put him up there
knock knock who's there adhesive
adhesive adhesive love it nice so so the
third thing the most important thing the
most important thing critical vital yeah
you have to give your blood once every
two to three weeks because if you do not
you start to develop blood clots from
this testosterone and you can have a
heart attack and or stroke this sounds
worth it yes
what do you mean you have to give your
blood what does that mean donate blood
because they have to take baseball who
wants this testosterone blood no the
testosterone blood is not a problem you
just your blood if you don't give it if
you don't if you don't give your blood
every two to three weeks or I think or
maybe once a month you start to develop
these blood clots and you need new blood
so coming so this is you have to get an
operation in your [__] you have to be
sure you don't get blood clots and die
you have to prevent yourself from losing
your hair you take estrogen pills to
balance everything out and this is also
you're gonna have a beach Bond the
soldier of Beachbody oh and the other
thing is once you make the decision to
take it you have to continue it for the
rest of your life because if you don't
then what happens is your body sometimes
doesn't always get the message even when
you stop putting the testosterone
tablets in you that they have to start
making testosterone and you will go bald
get tits and develop a whole array of
problems
so
what I say worth it
also can your body sustain taking that
much steroid over was it steroids is
just testosterone serves or two
different things no tests well steroids
steroids or anabolic steroids steroids
are like uh like I think HGH might be
considered steroid I could be wrong but
like you know D balls and Winstrol those
are steroids those are
I don't know what the different
testosterone is just literally giving
you testosterone which is a you know
muscle builder and you know life
enhancer supposedly and a lot of guys
will be able to get it legally from
their doctor and by the way what my
friend did is not illegal it's all legal
it's just you most men I forgot what
they should they're calling for him
that's it they're coming for these
glasses
um what most men have low your
testosterone starts to get lower as we
get older like you might have low T
don't I know but you wouldn't get the
one that he got you would get something
maybe like a weekly shot and just get
your testosterone to like where they
should be he's going like twice as much
as the legal limit to get [__] jacked
wow I think wow but I'm like and that's
when I stopped and I said can I can I
have ammonia time to talk to you about
intermittent fasting yes and I want and
but he wouldn't give me that moment
because he said I already got the
tablets in my ass I don't want to talk
to you anymore about it and does he not
did it not feel like it's they don't
care that's cheating
well that's the thing it's not really
cheating steroids is most of cheating
hola Fresca hello fresh America's number
one meal kit it literally has taught me
how to cook I feel so confident in the
kitchen now because hellofresh delivers
the the ingredients and I cook them with
my family I'm spending time with my
family and we're spending time together
in the kitchen hellofresh it's so good
they customize select meals they swap
you can have different proteins
different sides and a protein a veggie
dish whatever you want and if you just
have a delicious home-cooked meal it
really really is awesome they have the
ready in less than 15 minutes meals
which I love
um it's cheaper than shopping at the
grocery store
um high quality ingredients hellofresh
in my opinion is the best best meal
service it's awesome I love the food and
I'm learning how to cook it's it's great
and right now if you go to
hellofresh.com hey babe65 and use the
code hey babe 65 you're going to get 65
off plus free shipping okay that's
hellofresh.com hey babe65 use the code
hey babe 65 65 off plus free shipping
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
well here's the thing is we've been
again LED astray on the steroid
conversation they said that when we were
taught steroids are so bad you'll die of
cancer this will happen supposedly that
was all based off one study which was a
small amount of people in that study and
then actually the benefits of heh
testosterone and other starts they think
are more positive than negative that's
what they say but yes I would say it is
it could be cheating it's like when
black Comics use the n-word it's
cheating yeah it's just always you're
always going to get bigger laughs at
that that's true from white people who
can't say it but I want that to change
and I'm an advocate for that
don't your bowls end up intermittent
fasting yes yeah all of them all right
like don't they go away aren't they like
we've been here we're taking a break
there's no there's an array of problems
that happen when you start taking this
stuff but you do get jacked and rip and
for some people that's enough especially
if your girlfriend's 20 years younger
than you okay and the balls then don't
matter no then the balls don't matter
but the balls do matter every other time
they do well here's the thing if you
want to not have kids then that doesn't
matter what you care about them balls
then but that's the other option that's
the other thing is it also you have to
take a camera you have to take a pill to
give you spermogenesis because your
sperm starts you start to get low sperm
counts with this so again worth it yeah
this seems like a lot but people will do
it to stay in shape and for that
Vitality we don't celebrate in this
country getting older some countries and
and and civilizations celebrate getting
older who like a lot of tribes in Africa
a lot of tribes and people in India will
do will they celebrate getting older
they like look at like gray hair and
wrinkled skin as like Beauty like you're
like look at like it's like wow
congratulations like you're getting
through this life where we look at it
the just the opposite we're like so
scared of it that we'll do anything to
stay younger and it starts to look weird
like all those Venus Serena Williams
commercials that were the Super Bowl uh
on Sunday I love them but she got so
much work on her face and now she's
starting to look like a cat because she
doesn't want to look old and she was so
beautiful she can't work she's so young
she's so healthy but now she's got the
cat face I've been seeing a lot of
Madonna uh hate yes Madonna looks crazy
yeah I mean she's in her late 60s but
she looks like she's 40. I would still
eat the Booty like groceries but she
looks crazy right but not the vagina
because you can get throat cancer I get
throat cancer but the booty is is I I
don't know where the research is whose
vagina do you think DJ Khaled would
break his fast for
I honestly think DJ if I'm if I'm DJ
Khaled yeah the only vagina that I'm
gonna break a fast for if I'm known DJ
Khaled the way that I do know him yeah
is let's break down DJ Khaled Muslim yes
from Miami fresh freshmos Muslim from
Miami yes so I think literally the only
Muslim from you're having fun saying
Muslim that's all you have to say I know
it's fun because Muslim I've been
corrected multiple times Yeah by my my
friends who are Muslim and saying you're
saying Muslim and I'm saying well you
misheard it I said muslim right because
I want to say I want to say Muslim
because I want to but I also feel like
what's he saying Muslim he doesn't speak
in our dialect like that so I I don't
know yeah like a cow a cow in uh Saudi
Arabia would go Muslim
those glasses give you balance that's it
so let's just give you Powers yes so
you're saying he's a Muslim man from
Miami he's a Muslim man from Miami Miami
he's a Muslim man for me I mean so I
would
Miami I think literally the only woman
that I can think of Adam because
everybody else at Miami's he is is doing
it is doing it from what I hear down
there there's only one woman yeah he
would go down then okay on the vagina
you know again being from Miami the only
other Miami royalty Gloria Stefan only
answers technological conclusion one two
three four come on one two three eat my
what no one two three four come on no no
come on baby
yeah
I like it
um so I think that
I don't um
you know what man I have not uh eaten
the [__] in a long time
and that's not good probably yeah what
gives you a sore throat we know that
well have you noticed I haven't had a
sore throat right and that's what I know
I know when you're doing it when you're
not doing it no every time I come in I'm
like guys I got strapped
guys I got struck it's always when you
come back from Vegas yeah
um but so so yeah so did you like I know
it's been a few days ago but did you
like the Super Bowl this year what what
was your favorite moment of just the
four hours that you spent watching the
game the game the commercials the
performance what did you like if there
was one moment there was one thing that
really took me for a loop did you see
the 2B commercial where everybody
thought they sat on the goddamn remote
yes and that was good that got me good
it got us all good and I never I bet you
collectively everyone's like
what about you know what's a great thing
and again I know as if that was a
commercial you know it was a great thing
how about all the comics who got comics
from our like circle of people that God
and Super Bowl commercials yamanika H
Foley Tommy Paul's age Foley H Foley
Tommy Pope had a commercial at care.com
Super Bowl commercials they were great
in it oh [__] Schumer I saw the roasted
the peanuts Jeff Ross roasted the penis
that was directed by Neil Brandon
directed by Neil Brennan because I know
because I was up front and I lost my
spot to yamanika as we all knew we would
wow you were afraid what do you have to
say for that
wait did you go on on a dish no he told
me that I was up for it and then I I
actually was still thinking about it
until I saw the commercial and I was
like oh I must have missed it yeah I
think they only was only one
yeah yeah yeah
Schumer had a commercial uh and there
was some other any there was a couple
other Comics too that I saw this was the
most star-studded commercial Super Bowl
I've seen in a very long time seven
million in ad you can get a couple of
Rolexes with that you're kidding me
seven million in air for 30 second spot
the networks were seven million bucks it
costs for you to put your ad on there
there's 30 second spot that's it I
wonder that we were trying to figure out
if there it obviously is like like after
the game ended and they were on field
doing like the yeah yeah and then went
to commercial there I'm like this has to
be a steep discount right because the
game ended people like shut the TV off
right right you lose 30 40 viewership
gotta be yeah no one's staying there to
watch a ticket tape and watch Andy be
like wow yeah no yeah and then how about
this commercial I I did you see the
commercial it was the it was the Blue
Moon commercial but it was like yes I
did see that that I you know we should
do we should put like a clip Up of like
two bears one cave versus you know bad
friends just 30 seconds get have a good
all these views at the end say this is
when I was watching that with my family
we were like this is stupid like you're
giving a lot of air time for seven
million dollars to Coors Light and
Miller Lite but at the end that was a
company babe parent company oh they're
all in gotta be gotta be okay because
but but the reason why I actually think
it was a good idea because I remember it
as the Blue Moon commercial yes so I'm
thinking it did work those are the two
best commercials in my opinion yeah I
started to think of my head like I I
could make a I bet you knowing what I
know I could make a super it's easy to
make a Super Bowl commercial everyone
will talk about yeah
in the complete opposite direction make
people say what the [__] you could just
do something outrageous like if I just
I'll make a Super Bowl commercial for
you for free for free I'll film it on my
phone and it'll be the most talked about
Super Bowl commercial because it's
bucking the trend right because they all
of a sudden it's all these big high
concept ideas a bit you know a lot of
celebrity a lot of like you know what I
mean and it's like everyone's looking
for that then you'll stick out if you
just do some low rent ass weird [__]
you'll stick right out yeah like I
thought the Ben Affleck JLo commercial
was good that was funny that was funny
when she's like is this what you do all
day yeah yeah because I felt like my
life
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah except I'd be going to
accept that commercial would take place
on the Tim Hortons
laughs
um oh and how about this I was supposed
to go I got invited to the Super Bowl
party at uh the one and only Chas palm
and Terry's house couldn't go my baby
had diarrhea explosive diarrhea
everywhere hour and 40 minute drive in
the car Jazz made the executive decision
said we cannot go literally the
babysitting everywhere birth control
birth control it happens yeah so the
baby was diarrheaing everywhere so we
didn't go can I just tell you before we
have to go what I ate
so yes on Sunday yeah was it a cheat
it was did you it was an affair yeah it
was it did you do like doing the
Patriots on Sunday did you cheat I
cheated okay I like that yeah thank you
I cheated yeah I yeah I um I
you you were inflate gate I was
inflategate because because I've been
trying right yeah I've been doing the no
Suites on Saturday I've even moved that
up to now only pizzas on Friday I've
been trying to do only Pizza on Friday
only sweets on Saturday and
um you know kind of like watching when I
eat whatever so between 12 and eight
faster window well now it's 11 is six
okay
um but still yeah so I what I pretty
soon you need between like three and
three fifteen yeah that's what it's
going to come down to all right and um I
look like Elizabeth Moss I want to be
scary I want to be skinny this way in
case I ever do get impaled it's easy to
miss my vital organs and I could survive
so I here's what I ate and this is I'm
not embellishing okay I'm what I'm what
I'm about to tell you is real and I can
prove it if you'd like me to read the
order off the phone I'll read the order
you off the phone I'm gonna believe you
for your word you sure yeah I know okay
I know you long enough
so by the way shout out
um rustic Pizza
on Staten Island great food rustic pizza
from rustic Pizza
and don't stop me because there's more
after I'm done okay
from rustic Pizza what I got
no by the way I got this for my family
okay everybody my family Jazz and my and
the three kids took a nap what does she
want what does she want when the food
came yeah what did she want to show when
the food came they took a nap and by the
time they woke up about an hour after 80
of the food was gone okay so I'm just
gonna every listen to me and then
understand that 80 of this was eaten by
me okay understood
Noki with vodka sauce potato Nokia vodka
sauce
that's a that's heavy right there there
you go gnocchi
sauce a spinach and artichoke pinwheel
that's fun okay
it's dipping sauce uh vodka sauce I love
vodka sauce okay um
um uh pigs in a blanket but Italian pigs
in a blanket it was like spicy sausage
with fresh mozzarella cheese in pizza
dough pigs in a blanket six of them six
macaroni and cheese pepperoni bites okay
like mac and cheese pepperoni pepperoni
bites okay like deep fried anything okay
you had the diarrhea let's be honest yes
Garden salad with grilled chicken
because I do eat one salad a day okay a
small you you really ate the gardens
outside they're still going I ate the
garden salad grilled chicken where was
everybody else sleeping on the couch
when the food came I'm not I swear to
God again I can prove this to you okay
um uh then I got I I got a small
Margarita Pizza like a personal pan
pizza but with the uh like deep deep
dish crust okay
okay a Cannoli Pizza
a cookie butter calzone
listen to me and a tiramisil I had tear
myself yesterday pause shout out his mom
shout out his mom I order that I'm
looking at it I see my kids are not
going to want any of this my kids want
Papa John's I then order a a cheat I
said Okay
a stuffed crust large pie cheesy
breadsticks Oreo cookie bites two two
liters of Diet Pepsi
I ate 80 percent of it eighty percent of
it sell but you're not used to this
anymore your body went into did your
body go into shock my butt what was that
my body felt like I was getting pumped
with testosterone through my ass cheeks
how did you even what did you had to
break all that down
uh when I'm when I'm telling you what I
mean this I thought I was going to have
to go to the hospital
it wasn't it wasn't like oh my God
nausea I had right here like in a
pinpoint which usually if you can point
like pinpoint right to a problem in your
stomach that's usually an emergency that
means something I excruciating pain
pinpoint here for about 20 minutes I
thought I ate so much food I burst my
appendix that's what I thought Jesus
Christ how'd you keep going I really
like it's a Super Bowl I was so hungry
and I have been fasting and being good
and had for so long and I had a good
workout I was that I and and I just kept
going and I and I was eating it quick
and not thinking and not being present
with my food and not just slowly chewing
and all that and when I woke up I swear
to God Jasmine said when she saw all
that she said did your friends come what
happened and I said no I told it no I'm
intimate and slowing yeah it's slowing
that's a dad that's that was for you I
like it put it outside they're rubbing
off on me and I said to her I said no I
I ate all that and she said Chris
honestly tell me are you depressed and I
said no I said I just got hungry and she
was like you might have to go to the
hospital and then when she said that
like it almost happened right away I
started getting that pain I was on the
floor in the fetal position for like the
first half of the game oh my God but
then finally I just let out literally
the fart of all farts it was a fart so
it was a halftime show far it was a
halftime show far I would have I would
have detailed myself
right out it was where even even it was
more exciting than the Rihanna
performance yeah even the baby started
laughing even the baby was like sorry
because she's like [__] yeah yeah
where but it literally so I truly in my
heart believe that I and I might be able
to prove it that it's still in my heart
20 000 calories I think I had in one
sitting
wow that sounds like it no I and I I
wouldn't and how did you did you eat so
quickly that you your brain didn't
process the fact that you were gonna get
yeah because also that those carbs the
the the the carbs the sugar the [__]
the Cannoli Pizza the cookie butter cows
the cookie butter calzone was amazing
cream sauce the gnocchi cream sauce I
was dipping bread in it oh and then
garlic bread too and this is all from
rustic Pizza roasted pizza and Papa
John's so rustic Pizza almost killed you
rustic pizza and Papa John's almost
killed me but they didn't and rustic
pizza versus Papa John's this whole time
guess what this is an ad for Domino's
huh
come on don't be a fake don't be a flake
Don't Run Away
Don't Be Afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe